tam n'y a aucune raison pour que les
deux tableaux c'est ceux qui se moquent
sont souvent ceux qui sont les plus à
plaindre
là c'est bon tu grosses pattes et bim
des la meilleure tam et rendent alors
que la rentrée grâce à respecter ces
mamans s'ajoute le prochain qui rentrait
pour moi
ne fais tout le temps avec un mec me
regarde plus de secondes jarrosson
d'avoir une étiquette grosse sur le fond
zeego sais pas mais pour moi c'est très
joli
toi tu sais que le jeu est clairement
c'est un garçon non c'est pas ça
notamment les garçons cela correspond
bien
salut culbuto pas que ce que tu veux pas
montrer diego comment tu plonges faut
que tu m'uses que david ma vieille chose
que tu as plein de trucs dans le bide
on a 11
on commence
je crois qui est un garçon après tout
mahmoud génifique ne doit pas sortir
comme ça c'est un pas là halloween c'est
la fête des morts pas des prostituées
merci ça fait deux heures 17 heures
semble amy winehouse c'est quoi une
constitué je savais pas qui tu es drôle
en fait tu les as des fossés qui fait
que des conneries ont sûrement qui
t'arrive à la famille et je grandis look
away tout ça c'est n'importe quoi avant
les vacances stock l'a dit c'est mort
pour - changement stratégique des zags
sadi rénale au cinéma avec moi demain
ouais pourquoi pas elle est là
c'est sûr qu'il faut que gbagbo veut tu
veux pas vous le mec gentil j'ai pas le
premier contrat s'en sortant là on est
fille parce que les câlins dans les
toilettes